the new album you said deals with
struggles of uh alcohol are you sober
now
no sir
i am
responsible now
how'd you get responsible because most
people who have a problem with alcohol
they got to go you know you got to
either go one way or the other it got to
a terrible point
and um yeah
you asked some great questions
um
it was to a really really really rough
point and um i couldn't get up
off the floor for for for weeks and
that's what a lot of the inspiration for
the album comes but i don't want i never
want to
bring people down i just want to express
how i feel yeah but what were you
drinking i was screwdrivers it was a
bunch it was vodka it was vodka and it
was it was bodying fifths
and um
trying to hang in there and and talking
to people who weren't [ __ ] there and
trying to say that yeah could you help
me up you know um there's
hotel rooms and what do you think was
going on were you hating yourself were
you um did you ever get to the bottom of
it did you get help with it um no sir i
never got help with it i just
have
super beautiful people around me and
i met a really beautiful person that um
what made me feel like
uh a human being again and this is your
girlfriend
yes sir and and she was able to get
through to you and say look i i love you
but i can't deal with you and did she
give you the ultimatum did she say to
you look i understand you're your own
person
but if you want to be with me
you you got to make a decision me or the
alcohol
no sir and it's it's not
oftentimes whenever you're looking for
help or
subconsciously even seeking help it's
not
an ultimatum
is always
heartbreaking it's just like oh [ __ ]
you know what do i do it's it's the
guidance
it's the guidance out of the dark into
the light it's not like oh you pick you
know there's the show the dog or me
right it's it's not that it's right you
are you and i love you so much and i see
what you can be
and i know who you can be and i know you
you're not like this
and um yeah she saved my [ __ ] life
it's pretty epic
is there someone in your life
who like i know like you you love justin
bieber he gave you a break he put you on
tour with him in the beginning when your
career was going and you love you love
him you refer to him as your brother
were there dudes like that who had the
kind of fame that could turn to you and
say post
i love you you're [ __ ] up dude or was
this just something you had to figure
out on your own there was a time to
where i had so much guidance and and
justin was guiding me and justin was
like this but i'm like you know what
like i love you at the end of the day i
have to do what i want to do and that's
what i'm gonna do i'm not listening to
anybody
and
that's what i'm working on now
is an issue with being
told what to do because at the same time
people can look at you from the outside
and see that something's wrong
and you can be trapped in your own
[ __ ] world and it's an issue of
opening up and
i need to do a lot less talking and a
lot more listening
and um
i'm 26 and i'm and i'm learning every
[ __ ] day